I'm gonna join the weekly classical
arena and right away starting a game
playing new gam 12 I'm gonna play e5
also why is it lagging do I have I don't
have any other windows open let's play
Knight of 6 I'm gonna play a align which
I've been playing a lot recently Bishop
d3 when I teach students basic openings
I like to call this a pointless Bishop
it really doesn't have a great point on
uh I'm d3 let's just continue play
Bishop c5 the problem with the bishop is
a box of pawn which blocks other Bishop
just a bad Bishop so I'm not going to do
anything too special I'm just gonna plan
on completing development knight c6
really don't know why my computer is so
slow but I mean in classical chess play
it doesn't matter too much Bishop e2 so
he's realizing his mistake but now I can
take a free pawn hello to people in the
chats Palast again it's 4 a.m.
where are you 4 a.m.
it's like Australia well if you're about
to go to sleep you can say up for
another couple hours maybe
yeah Australia I guess makes sense
though either Bansky good to see you
camel clutch oh wow so many people from
around the world
cold player are there any Americans so I
think we have one one England one
Australian European okay let's just
castle so blacks up upon coach Paula's
American cool Brazil good afternoon
Samsonite let's play rookie Rookie eight
open file not sure how my queenside will
develop I might just go for like the
immediate kingside play like maybe Queen
f6 or Queen h4 so he's initiating some
trade
if I take on g4 Queen tech g4 then Queen
f6
there's some line which probably doesn't
work okay
I was looking at like sacrificing on f2
I forget this is classical I have like a
lot of time to think if I take on g4
Queen take G for Queen f6 C 397 maybe
I'll play a 97 right away like 97 9 F 6
could be useful
you know let's play 97 if he takes on g7
I'll get the bishop pair F 5 says
Vianney of KZ I didn't consider f5 maybe
it was playable but maybe it just hangs
upon cuz it might take off 5 is that
wall carpeted wait what do you see the
wall this is not carpet oh maybe the
other wall no this is uh there's wall is
just a wall without carpets okay so this
positions nice for black so I'm already
up upon I'll bring my knight to the
center ideally I would like to bring my
pieces all to the Kings side and just
have some attack I plays knife f5 looks
aggressive but ok the bishops are
staring at each other I think I'll just
play this pressurize this Bishop unleash
my own Bishop Knight take g7
I have no fear
yes no now we're just trading everything
and now I'm just up a piece and I have a
G file
maybe you'll play rook g8 and King h8
it's easier to attack with a half-open
file like this hello dr. dumb key you
just don't join the term into crush me
there's over a thousand people playing
this tournament so I don't think it's
likely that we'll play each other but
maybe we will who knows
hello - buddy t31 3 Steven is Daedalus
is back bowl hostage in doesn't
understand how I have so many different
walls well if you want to see there's
like some weird I don't know what these
are
it's like window drawer type shade
things this is a very old house let's
play King h8 hopefully I'm not mating
myself if he takes the bishop I'll take
back with pawn
nice to defend each other okay so he's
applying some pressure
do you have to be a little bit careful
that things don't immediately fall apart
we're just looking for like some quick
ways to win but it's hard to actually
break through to the king yeah I could
take the bishop and if he takes back
with the pawn I take the knight he takes
my knight I play rook g7 I'm still up a
piece please we got to there
oh then work f2 I have 94 let's go for
this line wait a minute but he could
take on e4 I take back on e4 it should
also be fine okay
I really don't know like why why is a
computer so slow I might have to things
are closed close maybe some additional
tab it's probably not more annoying for
me than that
like the viewers I mean it's a slow game
just it takes like an extra second to
make a move Fiona Chadha thanks for the
host
thanks for the auto host Lord of swarms
hello I joined late I joined so late
this is a five hour long tournament I
only have ever played like a full
classical tournament it's just too much
chess but maybe I'll do it someday if I
maybe for some like celebration if I
reach like five thousand Valerie's or
something I'll play a full classical
tournament hello Excise sparks good to
see you back okay so he takes some
nights so I have my Bishop should
probably save the bishop
like keep it on this diagonal directed
at the king g3 inviting Queen a Jew
inviting Maiden it's not made into but
okay g3 is not defended and Queen h3
will be coming Oh Queen h3 is force
meets no matter what he does like Queen
G - Queen h3 and then it's me even a few
more moves
okay good game yeah he gave me some some
gift in the opening Bishop d3
I wonder if Bishop d3 was a math slip so
you played Bishop e2 but probably just a
life regrets let's go back to
tournaments i rated rapid someday oh you
want to play me I don't think this will
be a viewer challenge stream but I will
have many more of those and I'll be
happy to play you I'll keep your name
and mine's magista ultimate moves event
was pretty Ultimates those were fun
events I was only there for the first
hour but I took some photos let's play
e4 people want to see the photos I took
I posted on Twitter
I posted a Twitter link which links to
my Flickr page
I'm the play of the four Knights or at
least of three nights for the time being
okay and now he's walking into the
center work trick this is nice
I usually do this as black a lot of
white players will walk into the same
idea but just as good after a night a
key five I'll play d4 and life is good
yeah ultimate moves it's um it's a very
stress-free event
I was kind of disappointed Kasparov
wasn't there because he he takes it very
seriously which makes it even more funny
but yeah that I think it was like their
fifth ultimate lose in a row their fifth
annual okay
d4 classic idea why it's not winning any
material like black could take the pawn
I'll take back with Queen but White's
getting some positional advantage mainly
more space and potentially two bishops
actually I was going over this with a
student earlier we were looking into
some interesting lines we were looking
at Bishop d6 this is just better for
whites night's attacks f4 should come
pretty soon
salty clown thanks for the comments okay
so now he's threatening some dirty
tricks with 9 f3
I have to watch out for I could play
Bishop e3 might be five looks enticing
defend an attack
not sure if might be five does anything
because I don't know if I'm threatening
to take on c7 there may be a ham that's
not enough three move is very annoying
if I play Bishop III he has a Knight g4
draw arrows for those of you who are not
well adept in notation so what do I do
maybe I just moved my queen Queen a4 I
have an idea Bishop e3 Knight g4 and
then ninety five and I attack attack and
if he takes honey three I win this Queen
that should be good if he takes on d4 I
preserve the bishop actually in this
line if he takes on d4 then I'm
threatening to win both rooks with my
take c7 and they should take g7 and I
don't don't think he can defend both
unless he plays King f8 but then I went
upon at the very least I'm in 550th
place a lot of catching up to do
well it makes the center fork trick so
good it's about yeah it's kind of a
tactical sequence that leads to
positional gain so yeah on the surface
it just seems like a trade but like
already in this position white just has
full control over the center and two
bishops you can't complain with that
let's Castle queenside unless there's
something better can i play off for now
maybe I should prevent Knight g4 cuz
he's preventing Knight d5 maybe I'll
play Bishop e2 and Bishop e2
decent-looking move and I'm actually I'm
staying flexible so I don't know which
side I want to castle Queen d2 95 is
also maybe possible
looks like Queen d2 and now I have plans
of this or this this night is gonna be
kind of stuck
and yeah another point of the center
fork
trick is white is a one winding up with
the pawn on e4 which leads to the better
space advantage and better centre
control and now I just want to expand
like I can play off 45 that would be
nice
is there a gap between I am and GM so
many questions from salty clown there's
a pretty big gap actually it takes a
long time like I'm and I am but I feel
like I'm nowhere close to GM but in
terms of like if I play the game against
the GM it would still be like a very
hard-fought game where okay i I could
win but to get to the GM level I would
have to be able to beat higher rated
players consistently just not easy to do
do you think a GM who couldn't play
blindfolded isn't really a GM I mean to
become a GM you need good visualization
skills so they kind of go hand in hand
ninety five two different targets you go
play queen g6 and counter-attack g2
things could get a bit messy
imagine queen g6 like a play F for Queen
d6 people putting their pieces in front
of their D pawns today not the best
approach but I don't know if I can
punish it I could lay out for like queen
C 3 threatening weensy 3 looks nice
actually threatening Bishop c5 yeah
let's do that
my queen isn't in good like relation to
the Knights where the night neither a
knight can attack the Queen so the
Queen's very safe additionally I'm okay
I have a tactical threat which is not
only a not only a skewer but it's
driving the Queen away from defending c7
so even if he moves the rook I could
still have Bishop c5 on top of that I
want to Castle and just put it a rook on
the D file so this queen is very
misplaced hello the ice hello toilet
noggin toilet noggin you haven't missed
too much joining it a good time
hello no joke a lot of returning people
and one returning one returning toilet
castling queenside looks attractive cuz
I'd no longer have Bishop c5 I could
play f4 and the knight has to go to g6
Queen is on the verge of getting trapped
at for night g6n Castle queenside now
let's just start with this because now
the threat is that for Knight g6 and
then e five and I just want to drive the
Queen away from defending c7 and in many
cases the only square for the Queen is e
six meaning I can just take on c7 and
for Kim dirt laughs it's so much hype
good to see you
I have one challenge though okay so
about oh that was a correspondence
challenge I'm not going to be accepting
challenges this stream unfortunately for
the people who want to play me I'm just
playing the classical arena so if you
want to join the arena it'll have like a
1 in 1,000 chance of playing me your
subscription is ending in four days oh
you're letting it expire to sub for a
higher tier that's exciting
that's very exciting I have to apply on
the stream for four days from now I have
to I have to re redesign my stream
schedule because my overall schedule is
changing which means I might do more
streams actually in the mornings or at
least earlier in the day just to
coincide and not to coincide but just so
I don't overlap with the sync felt Cup
coverage which starts tomorrow
can i play e5 that was the whole idea
I need tactics if he takes on e5 I'm
winning a piece if he doesn't take on e5
and still winning material there's a
funny line I don't know if it works but
Queen e6 f5 Queens I got 5 Queen takes
c6 that doesn't work
I was thinking 97 but the other night
control g7 as well so the simple
approach is just to take on c7 Queen e6
is the only square for his queen oh he
takes ok
so I'm up a piece c7 is attacked twice
but my knight is attacked twice looking
for discoveries I don't know if I see
anything that works I mean okay
everything probably works in the sense
is multiple winning moves I'm thinking
just Queen takes e7 and just trade stuff
and be up a pawn should be good enough
I'll be up a a Bishop for a pawn things
still all the new followers
unfortunately on my window like I see
the the vent list the people who
recently followed but the text is too
small so I can't actually read the names
but I can read gypsy Shaymin thanks for
the follow okay let's focus on just
getting this game over with I'll play
Knight d5 threatening with some more
tactics happy to trade further if he
wants I takes you seven would have won
the rook wait what if I take on c7
immediately I should have considered
that yeah cuz I'm attacking the Queen I
just assumed brick c8 but his queen is
attacked that was a better move your
rights miss anything else that was
simple
like I said I had multiple ways to win
but sometimes this will happen when
you're winning you just got lazy it's a
bad habit when you're winning you should
still strive to play the best moves you
need to combine a toilet and the Spanish
somehow if I had to say one word to
combine toilet and Spanish it would be
baño
anyway that's okay let's focus on this
position there's a well my bishops
defended by my Knights but the Knights
attacked by his bishop could just play
rook e1 rook e1 seems simple improve the
rook this is the only fully open file
for a tier 3 Emo's so maybe I need
something better than baño
ah Tier three emotes I'm working on
emotes I put together a folder of
pictures with different ideas which
maybe I can share it with people okay
now it's just a matter of converting
extra piece he's gonna play this and
I'll play this and life will be good
someday I'll play Bishop f2 I had to
pick one what's more important jump from
weights oh so you want to jump from 2300
to I am opening preparation opening
preparations very important but it
depends like it depends on what your
weaknesses are because I will say like
23 hundreds we'll still have like some
clear weaknesses or they have to fix
certain types of holes but of course at
the higher levels especially if you're
playing in like around robbing events
and you know here playing beforehand
I mean opening preparation is so
important like be able to see be able to
kind of digest what your opponent plays
the sense of their repertoire and like
be able to prepare specific lines for
players is a very big element from
getting like master to higher levels
okay so I can't get away with taking and
I can get away with this so it's a nice
move and now I'm attacking the rook and
attacking g7 if he takes the rook I have
to take back with King or of take g7
there's King f8 hello the fukes yeah
good to see you
a toilet speaking the word cabeza it
might be too hard to design in like a
128 pixel emotes it's not much space to
to have too much text along with the
toilets
okay c3 is solid and now I'll I'll go
for the doubling on the seventh rank and
that should somehow end inmates also let
me know if the audio is okay I've been
playing around with my mic settings and
like in previous streams when I talk
there's like this background noise which
happens only when I talk because of the
noise filter so I got rid of the noise
filter and hopefully it's okay
and I've also clipped the the mic to my
jacket so it should be even better
quality than normal
okay back to tournaments hey it's a sub
J doc thanks for the sub
give me one moment I have to reconfigure
things new game is starting okay
verbanski wait is this the leader
Urbanski did you say he joined the
tournament just to play me he joined the
tournament just to play me no way how
did this even happen let's play d5 it's
something different I said there's
there's a one in like 1,000 chance of
playing me and he gets to play me I was
like in response to his comments
we'll play a Queen's Gambit declines
good luck da weed did I end up keeping
the blue Yeti I do not have the blue
Yeti it doesn't belong to me
unfortunately but there's actually
there's another streamer who has a who
has exact microphone now who might be
streaming soon or later stay tuned for
that Bishop f4
there's about four I think I can take I
know it's a it's a playable line I think
there's some idea where I can play like
95
if efore this is working right
it's Koine for knight c6 I think this is
problematic for lights usually the
bishop likes to be on g5 but in this
case a move like a five walks into
ninety five and then the bishop is hit
and the knight is hit and life is good
there is a question earlier that I saw
but I didn't acknowledge I will try and
acknowledge but first let me take a pawn
kahe taro is asking where do I start
with openings for black you always
you're always so lost with black you
can't prepare one opening for every
opening white house yeah so the starting
point is you have to you have to
identify what to play against efore and
what ty then if I want to play misty for
keep those two separates against efore I
mean there's a variety of options
recommend like choose any Sicilian
variation learn the first few moves and
have that as your starting points but it
takes patience after every game you
should really look over it and see what
you weren't familiar with also can I win
another pawn I just take here with a
triple fork it's so enticing I guess f2
isn't is well it's efficiently defended
by whites but these things are not
sufficiently defended
norman david kaye thanks for the
comments i'm reading old comments now as
i missed a lot the microphone I'm using
is a samsung go mic
it was like 30 bucks and it has like the
cardioid setting and like the 360 like
multi audio setting so I'm happy with it
and it's super small Hungarian Hungarian
variation and dragon oh so people are
suggesting black openings to learning
yeah I'd say pick one opening and then
go with it he plays 92 which leaves two
things undefended I can draw arrows this
is undefended and this is undefended I
mean taking the bishop is just a free
bishop but taking the pawn does it lead
to more queen take f2 king d1 and I take
c3 pawn takes c3 I'll just take the
bishop
and now now I can just trade everything
don't know what to take with Bishop or
the Knights I take c3 pawn takes c3 that
I probably keep my bishop or Bishop
takes c3 pawn takes c3 choices choices I
actually like this better Bishop takes
c3 I like my knight in the center when
is my birthday
wait toilet noggin do not ship me a blue
Yeti for my birthday thanks for offering
though I have a blue Yeti at home I
haven't been using it for two reasons
one reason as I'm traveling and it's way
too difficult to travel with because
I've been traveling around Europe with
just a backpack the second reason is ooh
free bishop yeah this bishop is hanging
it's undefended pieces my opponent is is
so generous what was I saying
oh yeah the the second reason is the
blue Yeti is completely broken but I I
got it uh like a year and a half ago and
there's a two year warranty so I'm I'm
gonna ship it back and they're gonna
send me a new one I just have to I just
have to remember get back home to ship
it back so I should be having a blue
Yeti and in like a wait I'll get back in
a couple of weeks I should have it in
like mid-september hopefully for now I'm
just using my my travel Mike let's
castle
patro is the best dragon is the best
bond cloud is always better
okay I'm not I'm not missing too much in
the chat let's defend the Queen I'll
retreat the Queen and now I still have
to develop the Queen side there's
usually two strategies when you're up
material you can either just trade
everything or attack with the extra
material that you have attacking is a
more fun option also thank you thank you
the ice for the sub appreciate that
let's develop with tempo and the tagging
strategy is to fianchetto the bishop and
then target the G to fajn probably
someday I'll play 95
more questions from salty clown I don't
know if I can answer that last question
let's play b6 for people with no feet a
rating can it be said that they're
Czeslaw calm rating is what their feed a
rating would have been I will think
chest comm ratings correspond with feet
a ratings but maybe I don't know it
depends on the player I'm sure some
people they correspond a little bit okay
95 the ice with the bits toilet noggin
rocks that's nice
and so doesn't okay that's such a nice
such a nice comment let's play Bishop b7
okay so now we're both trying to attack
on the Kings side he's targeting g7 I'm
targeting g2 but I have a bishop and he
doesn't have a bishop
you just [ __ ] me and you working from a
laptop I might yeah I might change
laptops at some point cuz this lag I
think I just have to I have to clear out
my data cuz my storage I'm pretty sure
it's just very low because I've been
taking all these like pictures every
picture I take is like 25 megabytes
which really eats up the storage but
it's worth it just have to transfer it
to my external drive okay let's bring in
the rook let's bring in this rook get my
a pawn defended yeah the like my mouse
is really lagging but the board isn't
lagging also when I do this why does my
cursor just appear gigantic this is so
fun giant cursor okay let's play root d6
I wonder is that a little beat chess
issue or is that probably it's just
probably a computer issue for me that's
a cool feature though just if I move too
quickly
oh it's a new part of the operating
system so I can find my mouse so the
people are moving around maybe they
can't find it
that's great some interesting usability
there 64 chess King you the best another
one we the best take that as a
compliment
Oh let's win stuff or trade stuff mmm
okay we'll trade I could sack just to
open up the King okay good game our bats
key what went wrong I don't think Bishop
f4 is uh I know it's not like common
move I think the reason it's not common
is because of this line a black can take
maybe e3 is better there's some line
like III 95 Bishop takes you for and I
take out four pawns I got four and white
gets some space the black gets a bishop
pair okay so I dare play another game
you do have to figure out this computer
situation I'm getting challenges yeah
don't challenge me because I'm not
playing games I said that last time I
said that in the stream title last time
and people challenged me even more okay
let's play let's play d5 again stick
whistling with the same repertory I did
make a study not too long ago on the
chess called how to play against one d4
and I'm just following the repertory
based in that study because there's a
common question that I get a lot like
what what I recommend against e4 now
this variation is not in the study more
variations include white developing the
bishop earlier against the song in the
play of semi Slav and there's okay
there's multiple ways to play this I
mean black can probably the most
principled approach is to play something
like c5 or even maybe Bishop b4 check
and c5 but I mean the play c6 and we're
gonna go into uh like a mainline time
you Slav hello Bruno Rolla
good to see you a lot of returning names
if there's any new people here or this
is your first time watching I'd be very
curious to to know where you're from and
how you how you discovered the stream c5
oh this takes me back to childhood c5
was like one of the very first
positional concepts I learned my very
first coach I asked him like why this is
a bad move in the Slav and he said it
was because b6 85 and when I learned
this concept like it was just a light
bulb that went off like in terms of
understanding positional
positional play with pawn breaks the
fact that like whites position is just
falling apart
Queen a4 I've not seen before now I have
to think
Queen a4 I mean okay
I would like to defend my rook so I can
take the pawn maybe I can play Bishop e7
this should be southern and I defend c6
as well keeping all the tension let's
play Bishop e7 it looks like a terrible
Bishop being cathode like behind a pawn
chain but it defends the rook and
because of all this tension should still
play in in blacks favor
okay now I have to catch up with the
chats as my opponents suffer is in agony
positional agony tasteless calculator
really it's your first time
well welcome good to see you so I think
a lot of people will like watch on
YouTube and then find the twitch stream
through YouTube but some people just
find it to really chess b5 now I have to
think lots of tension does white have a
threat maybe he just wants to take and
play Bishop b5 but I mean I think I can
just win a pawn because this is attack
twice this is defended twice so let's
run upon if he takes on c6 I could take
with bishop or Knights
now to probably take with Bishop and
then play Queen b6
your internet has been bad I'm so sorry
about that oh you found me through st.
Louis chess club nice I think there'll
be a couple more videos on the channel
of lectures I did but they'll be
released only after the st. felt cup
ends if I'm not mistaken okay so now
Queen b6 I'll pre move actually I want
pretty move because maybe I can take
with Queen but yeah life is good we're
in a pond and I think it's it's very
common like once we reach this position
that white just ends up losing a pawn
like White's best move was probably to
take and just accept that c5 didn't
accomplish anything but he's keeping the
tension I'll probably keep the tension
too
I could take on d4 Knight 84 probably
helps White's
there's some lines where I'm looking at
like seat 84 and then Bishop to b4 all
right I leave my Bishop on c6 undefended
I go for counter play I mean it might be
the best approach actually but it's
complicated and I'm lazy but okay let's
calculate so you take T 4 and I take T 4
Bishop b4 can draw arrows I'm
threatening to take the night with check
also pinning the Knights so you could
take on c6 or you could play Bishop to
d2 plays Bishop d2 I trade on b5 I just
Castle and life is good so if he takes
on c6 with the night I take on c3 with
Chuck Danah fish of d2 I trade in castle
okay that also looks good so after
Bishop b4 if he takes on c6 with the
bishop I take with the Knights and then
he plays Bishop d2
probably the most challenging line then
I play rook c8 so after Bishop before
I'm looking at tick or no I'm looking at
Bishop take and I take and then Bishop
d2 I have rook c8 a or batts key with
the donation thanks for Bansky rook c8 I
don't know if I like that just seems
like I'm pinned rook e1 could happen or
b1 a3 can be annoying so my second
option is just Bishop d6 which could
walk into Bishop a3 but I just want a
castle yeah it's just there's a d6
Bishop e3
[Music]
I'm feeling the pressure so I'm
realizing he has lots of ways to build
up pressure like he has Bishop 83
because I'm giving him all the ideas and
he's probably watching so but I have a
feeling I if I play correctly I should
be able to neutralize everything just a
matter of finding the right line and
maybe I can just like take on d4 take on
b5 and play 97 if you take with Queen
take
realizing I might actually have to
calculate further like I should go into
that line after rook c8 I was saying
like rook b1 I might just have Queen c7
I neutralized everything yeah I'm gonna
go for this why it's gonna have some
short-term initiative but hopefully it
doesn't lead to any like huge deficits
also I've kind of stopped paying
attention to the chats I look at the
chat in the future
anyway and I take tea for let's play
this would be for it's all based on my
earlier calculation I'd like one more
move here to just castle and trade on b5
that would be nice but now it's up to
white to try and keep some some pressure
I'm trying to catch up with comments
lots of discussion toilet now again I
love to get coaching a couple times a
week but you believe I'm so busy I've
been really busy this past month my
schedule will open up after way I'm
trying to think ahead castling was not
expected let me think I had in this
position and I'll think I had in my life
okay can I just Castle - or I could just
trade on b5 and then Castle trying to be
five take take take castle I'm up upon
look simple
I'll be free starting a September 4th
because I'm playing a tournament yeah
I'm playing a tournament from the 1st
through the 3rd then September 4th I'll
be I'll be a free person eyebrows on on
fire from the Bay Area Bay Area has a
great chess scene of a number of
students from the Bay Area while the
friends there - ok well trade Queens and
the knight coming to b5 and potentially
c7 doesn't scare me because I can Castle
I can also play King d7 which actually
looks very reasonable here because we've
traded Queens just a question is the
King useful on c7 or is it a target on
c7 think it's useful might help like
prepare Roxy at some points in spiking
d7 I've given this lesson to students
before like when Queens got traded early
your king should usually be in the
center and usually you don't have to
Castle if if your king is not being
exploited
x-eye sparks with some bit thanks excise
sparks astana with the raid I didn't
even realize that that was a while ago
thanks with Stena astana has a great
stream because he I don't think he gets
distracted like me like he just focuses
on like good quality commentary and he
has uh is a very good voice for for
commentary and just explaining things
and in simple manners and he's strong
too killed me a bunch of times and
bullets okay a 3 a 3 makes me happy
because now as bishop can't come to a 3
question is do I go here here here
meet Bishop c5 maybe initiate some more
trade then my knight will likely come to
a6 in my rooks well someday come to the
the files what software am I using to
broadcast I'm using OBS which I think
takes a toll on the computer a4 is a
good move now he wants to give he
reinforces the Knights and maybe he
wants to play Bishop a3 but it gives me
the be for square which is nice vo in
Chadha Hollow fianchetto by the way
thanks for the auto host about a half
hour ago don't know if you you were
aware of that I'm really behind in the
chat I'm responding to messages which
probably took place like five minutes
ago so hopefully people who gave
messages are still existing in the chat
ninety five is actually kind of annoying
it's a good move Bishop d6 I don't
really want to trade off my dark squared
Bishop but maybe it's playable thing is
the worst-case scenario if I allow 95
King e7 which is just really solid so
let's just continue let's play rook to
c8 and when the night comes to e5 it can
be targeted with Bishop d6 or 97
lots of ex slams oh you liked my duel
with Costilla yeah that was fun like to
do more of those how often do i watch
The Lion King once every like 15 years
so I'll probably watch it again when I'm
like thirty okay this should be set
Bishop to be to read night before my
nights not doing much on a six and now I
have juicy looking moves like 93 or
night c2 so he has to watch out for four
possibilities like rook c1 can run into
ninety three hello Luke be benign good
to see you
while the people new to twitch
lots of good messages that's what I like
to see
toilet noggin giving people the benefits
of of subbing this might be my last game
but we'll see getting getting some
messages I wanna I want to go to the
autograph session they're having if
there's anyone in Saint Louis they're
having an autograph session today at
just a couple hours with all the players
what I like to do is buy like the the
chess player training cards trading card
trading cards whatever they're called
and and just got all of them signs and
then give them away as gifts to likes
tunes and so like after school classes
they're a good form of bribery to get
kids to pay attention anyway rook d1
there are threats I don't think there's
no threats
I might just play Keaney southern
because my king is just happier they're
off the file of the rook away from being
checked by either Knights a few months
ago I was teaching an after-school
program I I got all the cards from u.s.
championship signs and I had the kids
just like pick just a card at random or
at least the kids who behaved and one of
them they picked the Fabiano card i felt
bad like just giving away
Fabiano like signs card to a random kid
but the kid was happy so it was worth it
there's a v5 is there a threat might see
7
I want to play 94 of it hangs g7 maybe I
can play 98 like 98 at 6:00 and then
uncoil with like 96 its play 98 my night
in some sense restricts is Bishop and
yeah if I got the pawns f6 as Bishop is
less powerful and then his knight will
be less powerful this is night hanging
away what weight was c3 hanging on some
points o in the previous position yeah I
I was considering taking on c3 I
honestly didn't look too deeply into the
sign I just assumed that I was losing c6
like Knight Bishop takes c3 Knight takes
c6 I could have calculated could take
the rook he could take on b8 I think I
played quickly there cuz I just saw I
was winning a pawn maybe I could have
one more okay
like every movie play is the first
question I ask is what what's the threat
cuz every movie is playing is it looks
like an active move I don't think
there's a threat because my Brooks
defended on CA my bishops defended so
I'm gonna just continue with f6 you
would like to play rook takes e5 rook
takes e5 and Bishop d6 but my knight
controls d6 hello car Mar good to see
you back okay I can take and then just
trade that's what I want and then I'll
play 96 and the extra pawn should be
enough to to get the job done as long as
I don't plunder katraine Knights there's
also a funny move Knight e3 taking
advantage of back drink mate stuff I
think I'll start with 96 oh wait a
minute
96 97 could be weird because if rook a
70 isn't I take d5 oh but my rooks
defended okay yeah my knight defends a
rook so I thinking this this take I can
just take and then I win material
your kids prefer been Feingold over me
I'm so so insulted but then I mean wait
a minute I forgot you six is hanging
this is bad ah carelessness distracted
by been Feingold comment I'm just gonna
play in that on been Feingold
or I could blame it on your kids I think
I read that comment after making the
move though
that's probably just my fault well this
is okay that's really disappointing
I didn't identify the threats and ninety
seven was actually it wasn't a threat I
just allowed it
there's some cases where I might sack
the exchange
thanks for the sub say is chess I'm I'm
highly considering sacking the exchange
here but it's probably not called for
bits from karma I think I'm gonna play
rook a7 allow him to take on e6 and then
put a knight on c4 it's not to make sure
I'm not plundering or things because g7
is hanging it's really unfortunate
what's going on after E 5 e 5 he takes
on the eights I take on d4 he takes on
CA they take moves his knight back
[Music]
Knight c4 immediately is also a move she
nicely for immediately might be the best
practical choice because I keep all the
files closed guess he could play e4 in
some cases like he takes on eight rook
take a it and then need for I could play
Knight be too when the a for pawn rook
c7 looks really risky I think I'm gonna
go for it though
looks really wrong I'm trying to find
like a clear reason why I shouldn't go
for it
oh that reason might be might take a 6
yeah this is bad maybe Rick p8 then rook
b8 he takes on u6 and I just played some
g6 and just equal material I've isolated
pawn but it's playable I'm gonna play a
rookie Yates try and keep my composure
I very could have you easily lost my
composure to play Knight c4 and then
just fall apart really quickly but
sometimes when you blunder you just have
to reset you accept the facts in this
case I'm losing a pawn I'll play g6 and
the game will continue
yeah I'm really far this chat how did I
get started with chess when I was 7 I
was really into like puzzles I had that
long longer attention span than those 7
year olds so I got into it pretty
quickly there's actually a documentary
where I'm one of the main characters and
like the the beginning of it it talks
like they interview me how I got into it
it's on YouTube somewhere
I play rook d7 g7 he's going to bring
the light back to b5
yeah we're just trading stuff I don't
think I'm too much worse if he plays
might be five maybe I'll play Knight c4
and try and fight for some advantage
where am i right now I am in st. Louis
in the USA did I go to university
University I went to a University of
Illinois for two years and then I
transferred to Western University
because Webster was much much cheaper
and they offered me a chess scholarship
and they had the major that I I I was
more interested in studying
I studied interactive digital media
which is maybe not the most common major
but it's it's a combination of like web
development design anything relating to
like media and technology so it's
actually overlapped well with chess
night db5 out is not expecting because
this night looks really awkward I'm
wondering if I can just play because he
wants to take on g6 I wanted to play
King g7 I can calculate King g7 but then
he takes that's bad
okay so I could take on if I take on b5
he can oh he can take on d5
this is getting really confusing so he
gan b5 take on d5 and I can take and
I'll have two nights for a rook and a
pawn so night take b5 he probably takes
back with the Knights
and his night as strong maybe I maybe I
can play Brooksie for their Roxy for
wrote a C for do you take C for Luke C 1
rep g7 g3 or King F 1 and I can't hold
my pawn I think the only move is to take
take take okay the one good thing about
this position is that my King is closer
to the center the one bad thing is I
have a nice side pod so it's actually an
interesting imbalance where ya White has
a very strong structure but my king
could be more useful in many cases
especially if we trade off all the rooks
then my King is closer to winning his a
pond so if it's possible I would like to
just trade off all the rooks but I don't
know I can trade off one pair but not
more than that
and the night is so strong
I probably like to trail off in that if
I can Ju off like that all the rooks and
the Knights and it's just winning that's
hard to do so what do I do here
rook there's a couple options I could
play rook bb-8 I could play you're up
take c1 King g7 might be a move I'm
trying to look for like a longer term
plan
some idea to take on c1 then play Knight
d3 and then depending where the rook
moves
I would like to attack the a pawn or
even bring the Knight to c4 probably go
for that
someone hosted Johanna try is hello
Johanna thanks for the host okay I need
to move quicker because time is a is of
the essence rook see two kind of
expected now I can't play Knight b2 or
night c5 so the goal is to put the night
on c4 it should be easy to achieve and
then once the night gets to c4 it
restricts his restricts his opened file
and then I have ideas of attacking a
pond and there's some cases if I got my
knight to b6 and he plays rook a to I
can get away with taking because it
leaves as Knight undefended and just a
disclaimer I'm so but far behind in the
chat that I'm not looking at any like
current comments but feel free to
interact amongst yourselves I'm just
gonna focus on the game rook c8
interesting move I think I'll still play
Knight c4 but he wants to play rook h8
when I play King e6 94 check what's
going on
94 check King d6 I think that's okay
this point I might just have to rely on
intuition and this is a position I think
all three results are possible like and
wind blackened way and I could be a draw
g8 is slightly strange because he's not
even attacking the pawn now my king is
going to get kicked around a little bit
completing f7 - let's start with King e6
okay it's interesting now if I really
want to I could play Knight b6 rook take
a five and I take a four and that will
probably just be a dead draw I'm
thinking about just King g7 so
everything's defended
I want to do this and this and this and
this and then this and this that would
be nice so maybe he'll start thinking
whoa just knocked over a lamp it's okay
the floor is carpeted just not the walls
so he has time here this could be a long
game if he's like starts thinking and
then there's increment I mean I will say
I'm playing for a win which might
involve taking risks and risking losing
but that's the nature of chess okay
finally I'll scroll through the chats
and see I missed a lot
Gabriel hello Gabriel Gabriel I think I
got your message I haven't gotten to
reply to you because the last few days
have been really hectic but I will reply
to you very shortly and what I've been
telling most people is that or what I
said earlier
is that I I'll have availability for
lessons starting September 4th at least
for uh for new students why is an e5 an
option I probably should have played a
five before I I plunge earn my pawn on
e6 and some old comments
just documentary ah there's actually two
versions of the chest documentary
there's another one on YouTube which
actually I prefer a bit more but the one
on Vimeo is uh it should be that should
be free open to everyone
can we the chat get one more game after
this probably because I've been blacked
so many games it depends how long this
game is is gonna last because I want to
attend the autograph session I want to
go for a run I don't know if that's
gonna be possible I do not have padded
walls but I have like this um I don't
know what these things are like this
thing it's like a drawer with like kind
of drapes a little bit strange
so whenever the opponent is thinking
it's usually good practice to try and
predict what they're gonna do and then
calculate further especially when you're
low on time but I'm not really doing any
of that just catching up in the chat I
feel like if I talked out loud and was
trying to predict what he's gonna do it
would just give him things to listen to
so I think this is a plan also so many
subs at knotting such a good time I
don't want to get distracted I think you
can see six Kings he six all the noise
promise he has rook c8 maybe I can
repeat once yeah
repeat in game time thank you toilet
noggin and welcome to the new subs
through the generosity of the toilets
hex storm 59 as a sub TR TR nine Buster
DX nice Alan what should I name my dog I
came up with a great chest dog name from
the other day yeah I'm gonna repeat once
I think you should name your dog pet
Routh after the Petrov opening this is
scary or xe5 I did not see coming
because now he's targeting both my
potential weaknesses what to do
92 in the air might be six as a move but
he plays Knight c3 I could be losing a
pawn here I have to play King e6
I mean the rook is awkward on c5 but
it's hard to trap she always has access
to see aids it's even hard to attack the
rook okay now like I'm tied down to f6
if I play this he probably mates me
somehow I have four so I have to play
this so that didn't really work out I
feel like he's just improving and I'm
not making any progress
good move
as a trick I want to play but it doesn't
quite work I really want to play rookie
one here and he just takes the rook what
to do
96
okay I have an idea it's a really sad
move but really don't see what else to
do lyric d7 but then rook c5 wait rook
d7 rook c5 King e6 57 he just takes with
check and he's up a pawn yeah this is a
really sad move and I'm probably going
to get punished for it but I don't see
what else to do
I'm accepting that I'm losing the d5
pawn and it's a flexible move because at
least I'd move my king sweet it's not
coming with check and I have some
counter play positions like this is
solid all about counter play the sad
thing is I'm probably just fighting for
a draw Bob sock Amano says just resigned
that's the last thing I would do in this
position if you haven't seen my play
like I I don't resign when I'm down the
pond
especially when I have counter play and
there's some okay there's some decent
counter play here like rook d2 I could
trade nights I'm still down upon there
[Music]
anything anything else cuz there's also
night ePHI which gives away another pawn
but it might be worth it
yeah I think I'll play 95 I would rather
have activity then trade off more stuff
so my work is active it's very possible
I could start winning some pawns like
this you still have some hope and
there's a ten second increments so I
have I have ways of getting more time
why not rook F to you because my knight
was attacked I have to defend the night
King g7 I think the simple idea is just
to play this move
and go after f2 he moves I fall I win
the Jeep on accepts if he plays this
then I have to be very careful I think I
can play this there's also this I would
love to play this threatening this but
then he has rook c6 and nothing's quite
working so I'll go for this so this is
attacked there's actually some nice idea
which okay I no longer have
wait a minute is this oh no this is not
a draw be a funny draw 9f2 there there
there I mean okay I'm gonna take the
pawn he's going to take the a pawn
that's not good though
play h5 there are those problems in some
lines where I'm losing the H fun in 26
seconds to ten over ten minutes at least
I'm giving him a choice I'm still making
him think here like he could okay he
could win a five he could try and defend
can't really defend you to get something
I'll take on g2
I'll probably keep my fates this is a
reason why I play h5 maybe I could play
h6 but then an f6 I'm getting mated so I
have to play King f8 yeah cuz if I
hadn't still had the pawn in h7 he would
just win it now in this case maybe
there's some sneaky ideas let me just
check
I'll see which way the King runs the
rook Knight combination are that it can
be very tricky sometimes terms of
attacking the king
especially when the king is cut off
unfortunately in this circumstance don't
think I'm going to be achieving too much
wait I would be happy with a draw I
would be very happy with a draw
so just repeating once I'm happy to get
more time weights he's just he's
agreeing to a draw okay
that was strange I mean he can probably
just be winning after King f1 I wonder
if he meant to repeat only twice but he
accidentally repeated three times there
is I actually went over this in a
lecture once where he it like if the
king is closer to the edge then it's
it's actual repetition and that's what I
was actually hoping for go to analysis
board here in this position I was hoping
to set up rook t2 if we imagine okay Y
can do something like a five that I
wanted to play ninety one and this was
my hope to actually like force a draw as
after night let's say f6 this is just
repetition and this is a really nice
classic idea it's required like the
rooks on d2 in the Knights on f3 because
if the King ever goes into the corner
it's just mate and otherwise if King f3
then it's just repetition so only only
blacking him in this position if the
King runs away too far so it's very
strange like that he accepted a draw in
a position where okay the king can run
away and maybe the King can even run
away this way this is probably the best
option it looks weird to put the King in
the corner but I ran out of checks and
then as a pawn his past as a pawn has
passed maybe he could like achieve this
sort of mate
classic meeting idea anyway that was an
interesting game I mean the opening was
great for me I just I I blundered upon
can I say
I allowed Ikey okay he wondered upon due
to the positional play that i blundered
due to carelessness in 96 just a very
bad move
I just had to be patient maybe team d7
Peter suggesting a 5 also playable well
lesson kind of learned want to check one
thing
I was hoping to to raid another streamer
but I don't think they're streaming
right now refresh this No okay well I
have things to do today
I'm sorry I it was hard to keep up with
the chats all these games scrolling up
here people packing toilet bagging for
subs uh-huh I don't think I missed too
much people suggesting loose okay
I'm gonna end it here I would encourage
everyone to watch not only okay not only
like the next week of chess of the sing
felt Cup but they're streaming the
opening ceremony tonight should be
around like six I believe or seven which
should be on the st. Louis Chess Club
YouTube channel but with that I'm
departing and I'll probably be back in
the future hopefully and I'm working on
putting together a stream schedule for
this coming week so stay tuned for that
and good bye to everyone